it is this coming to be of science as
such or of knowledge that is described
in this phenomenology of spirit
knowledge in its first phase or
immediate spirit is the non spiritual
that is sense consciousness in order to
become genuine knowledge to beget the
element of science which is the pure
notion of science itself it must travel
a long way and work its passage this
process of coming to be considering the
content and patterns that will display
therein will not be what is commonly
understood by an initiation of the
unscientific consciousness into science
it will also be quite different from the
foundation of science
least of all will it be like the
rapturous enthusiasm which like a shot
from a pistol begins straight away with
absolute knowledge and make short work
of other stand points by declaring that
it takes no notice of them
so from section 26 we realize that on
the one hand the individual needs in
order to develop in order to truly
express what they are as spirit as guys
science and on the other hand science is
in a even when it's developed a sort of
unfinished state so long as it is not
incorporated the individual into it so
long as science does not actually become
conscious of itself how is that going to
take place well here's where angle
actually brings up the title of the book
what is the phenomenology of spirit
he says it's this coming to be a science
as such or knowledge as described in
this phenomenology of spirit now why did
he pick that title well you know spirit
Geist mind encompassing everything from
philosophy to religion to law to culture
to the Natural Sciences to the arts all
those sorts of things
are comprised within within guys so the
phenomenology of spirit phenomenally
phenomenall Logie does Geist what is
that about about all these human
activities endeavors achievements so
what is the phenomenology meaning that
well you know if you think about the
Greek term the phenomena that which
appears phenomenology would be the
science or the study of what's appearing
how is it appearing well it's appearing
in a lot of different ways but it's
appearing differently over time and
Hegel is seeing a progress not a
progress in the sense of a steady
drumbeat
you know everything just keeps getting
better and better it's possible to have
setbacks as a matter of fact if we take
away where Hegel you know probably went
wrong and thinking that history ended
essentially in 1807 we might even think
that the 20th century in part of the
21st century might have actually been a
period of decline as far as the
development of the dialectic perhaps we
need to rise up yet again that's a
bigger question that I think I had to
throw out there let's come back to this
actual chapter that or in that chapter
of a section
he says knowledge as it begins immediate
spirit in its first phase is the non
spiritual why I mean it's mental right
knowledge is in our heads well remember
it has to have that sort of reflexivity
it can't just be something in a book
over there something that could be
turned into say an algorithm something
that can be totally external to to a
subject knowledge has to actually become
subjective in the sense of becoming not
necessarily aware of itself as a bit of
knowledge like a book looking at itself
thinking about itself but through us
through us we are the ones who bring
spirit into the equation
so he says knowledge in the first phase
is the non spiritual that is sense
consciousness what we're looking around
at things we're not necessarily engaging
our intellects to a certain degree we
are insofar as we have to construe the
things that are around us we have to
think through categories of causality
you know be able to classify things even
if we're just like in a hunting
gathering we have to do actually
hunter-gatherers are pretty smart you
have to do a lot of problem solving and
speculation but still it's time
primarily to to sense impressions to
sense
consciousness to being taken up by by
the world around us if we think about
pleasure and pain that way very basic
sense experiences part of our
sensibility are our manifold than that
that way
that's non spiritual it's not going to
actually lead to great development
unless something else comes into the
picture and that unless is really key
here so he says in order to become
genuine knowledge in order to beget the
elements of science with the which which
is a pure notion of science itself pure
notion or concept and by this he doesn't
mean some little idea somewhere here
again he means something like a nexus of
of everything that goes into what
comprises a scientific viewpoint upon
things so this is a finished position
this is where we aren't yet Hegel thinks
that he's reached that point because
obviously he's writing the preface to
the phenomenology of spirit which he's
finished he's ready to preface after all
of that but we're not there yet
how do we get there your work your
progress and you know if we actually did
this according to scale this should be a
much much longer arrow and it should be
broken up into all sorts of some dead
ends and some cul-de-sacs and some you
know veering on it this way and veering
off that way but you know we simplified
it quite a bit he says this process of
coming to be considering the content and
patterns it will display therein and
then he gives us some cautions about it
that's what the phenomenology of spirit
is that's what this whole book is
chock-full of is the map that these
great explorers have traversed in moving
away from sense consciousness through
all sorts of other shapes of
consciousness eventually too with Hegel
genuine knowledge and he says I
caution you against three things that
this isn't so what's the first one he
says it will not be what's commonly
understood he has an initiation of the
unscientific consciousness into science
this will not be like a biology 101 a
botany 101 a even ethics 101 because we
can talk about moral science sort of
class where we reduce everything down as
best we can to the simplest elements and
try to make sure that we have accessible
texts that are easy for people to get
into he's not going to try to pull any
punches he's not going to water anything
down this is going to be a long arduous
process and you know it's not like you
can jump from here all the way to here
nor is it you know there's a lot of
people like to do can you just read up
to them you know the master-slave
dialectic and say okay I've got Hegel
now because there's a lot more to the
story so it's not going to be like that
it's actually gonna require us to work a
lot harder than if we were taking a
survey class it will also be quite
different from the foundation of science
Hegel is not foundationalist in the
sense that we're going to get the
foundation all figured out first and
that will be indubitable or at least
we'll have sort of an inductive
certainty about it and then we'll move
from there to build up stuff I mean
that's great if you can actually do that
turns out that in most things you can't
we're already in process we're already
moving along so we need to be able to
figure out how to sort of build the boat
as we're sailing it but he also says
least of all will it be like the
rapturous enthusiasm which like a shot
from a pistol begins straightaway with
absolute knowledge and make short work
of other stand points by declaring it
takes no notice of it we've already seen
the rejection of the sort of appeals to
intuition and Hegel says absolute
knowledge is something that we're going
to achieve
eventually it's not something you get to
assume from the start and say we've
already got this because if you do that
you're never going to actually make this
work you're never actually do the
progress because you're going to say all
of that I don't really need it what that
means is that the person who claims to
have that sort of absolute knowledge
actually does the person who does have
absolute knowledge can look back on the
entire development and have seen how to
progress through it because they
actually themselves had to work to
attain it and this would be what Hegel
is saying his own condition is and this
is what Hegel is sort of promising to us
if we make our way through the
phenomenology
the task of leading the individual from
his uneducated standpoint to knowledge
had to be seen in its universal sense
just as it was the universal individual
self conscious spirit whose formative
education had to be studied as regards
the relation between them every moment
as it gains concrete form and a shape of
its own displays itself in the universal
individual the single individual is in
complete spirit a concrete shape and
whose whole existence one determinate
Ness predominates the others being
present in a blurred outline in a spirit
that is more advanced than another the
lower concrete existence has been
reduced to an inconspicuous moment what
used to be the important thing is now
but a trace its pattern is shrouded to
become a mere shadowy
outline the individual whose substance
is the more advanced spirit runs through
this past just as one who takes up a
higher science goes through the
preparatory studies he has long since
absorbed in order to bring their content
to mind he recalls them to the inward
eye but has no lasting interest in them
the single individual must also pass
through the formative stages of
universal spirit so far as their content
is concerned but as shapes which spirit
has already left behind as stages on a
way that has been made level with toil
thus as far as factual information is
concerned we must find that what in
former ages engaged the attention of man
men with a mature mind has been reduced
to the level of facts exercises and even
games for children and in the child's
progress for school we shall recognize
the history of the cultural development
of the world traced as it were in a
silhouette this past experience is the
already acquired property of universal
spirit which constitutes the substance
of the individual and hence appears
externally to him as his inorganic
nature in this respect formative
education regarded from the side of the
individual consists in his acquiring
what lies
at hand devouring his inorganic nature
and taking possession of it for himself
but regarded from the side of universal
spirit as substance this is nothing but
its own acquisition of self
consciousness the bringing about of its
own becoming and reflection into itself
in section 28 Hegel is telling us more
about this big book that he's written
the phenomenology of spirit and he's
telling us not in these terms but that
is essentially a story of coming to age
for what he calls the universal
individual that is spirit Geist
mine now this is a long long story and
it begins far in the past and we can ask
ourselves is it leading up to the
present is it leading up to the what's
for us two centuries past of 1807 second
edition I think in the 1840s or is it
about our present and perhaps even the
future those are things that we need to
clarify and how far back in the past
does it go but now is not the point for
us to actually try to set those
determinations down the hard and fast we
want to see what's the general structure
of this and how does it connect with
other individuals so for example ancient
Greeks Socrates is Socrates somebody who
could be thrust into the presence as is
like for example that that you know
recent book Plato at the Googleplex you
just sort of you know update him and
bring him in and sit him down and he you
know gets off to speed pretty quickly
and then it starts asking a lot of
questions could we could we do that sort
of thing
perhaps we could because those were
individuals who were what we call world
historic they were furthering the
advance of sphere they're making some
sort of advance they were developing
things beyond where they were what they
found and they were doing so through the
development of their their being of
their consciousness but they only went
from here to here and maybe another
individual
it goes from here to here and another
individual goes from here to here and
you know yeah we if we were trying to
depict the dialectic we would need one
gigantic arrow and and the little
advances would be considerably smaller
some of them would be longer than others
but they wouldn't be that direct so he
said the task of leading the individual
from his uneducated standpoint in the
past or in our contemporary presence
can't be seen in its universal sense
just as it was the universal individual
self conscious spirit whose formative
education had to be studied studied by
who well studied by Hegel studied by
others before him because Hegel doesn't
see himself as having no predecessors
whatsoever
it's not as if nobody has ever studied
the development of culture and the
process by which and this is something
just amazing about human beings we don't
have to reinvent everything every single
generation so long as culture can bring
us up to speed through our processes of
Education and development as new
individuals so for example my father
taught me mathematics and he began when
I was about in a rigorous way when I was
about four years old because they had an
aptitude for that now he was able to use
a calculator to get me interested in it
so there's a little technological device
and that could have only happened in the
1970s or afterwards as a matter of fact
he probably could not have gotten me
interested in it by using a calculator
today I'm not sure that it would have
the same sort of semi magical effect on
a kid as it did you know in 1970 when
video games were
that time in a pong and space invader of
asteroids
what's going on through this entire
historical process of development one of
the terms that Hegel is not using so
much here but they're going to be
playing a major role is in German
Gestalt it's often translated as form or
shape structure we're talking about
Gestalt philosophy we mean the the
properties that a hole has when it's put
together that are different than than
the parts so for example this diagram is
a Gestalt because each of the elements
is arranged in relation to each other
and we're not in the same meaning if we
took out some of the things now angles
walks in terms of Gestalt and that's the
plural shapes of consciousness so
everything but his view is that through
history people are sort of working out
these these dynamics they're going
through these structures these shapes of
consciousness one of them one important
want to say the dialectic between you
know master and slave or Lord and
bondsman if you prefer the older
translation whereby the slave is put to
work basically through threats and
through it through being having force
imposed upon them by the master and the
master is then able to enjoy objects
through the mediation of the slave the
slave continues to develop the master
only has pleasure and doesn't continue
to develop in this this progression
slaves not entirely happy after
developing and actually
I'm happy consciousness which is a
different Gestalt a different shape of
consciousness so the universal
individual has been progressing through
these that's why at different stages in
history human beings are primarily
focused on different issues on different
goods on different questions because
there is progress it could also be
because there's declined to in some
cases although Hegel is not going to
focus on the decline in this to a
certain degree does in his philosophy of
history so he says the task of leading
the individual had to be seen on his
universal sense the single individual
myself or even one of these people who
who played a role is an incomplete
spirit a concrete shape in which and in
whose whole existence one determinant
Nastase so for example socrates was not
all of athens he does not represent all
of athens that's why he got killed by
the Athenians because so many other
people were like yeah that guy's got to
go and they they voted to do so and
there were other people who represented
things you know if you think about a
platonic dialogue different people are
presenting different ways of thinking of
acting of being of relating to other
people of making arguments of arranging
goods so he says if we look at it in the
big picture the single individual is is
incomplete in a spirit that is more
advanced than another the lower concrete
existence has been reduced to an
inconspicuous moment this is a key idea
so there's actually progress in a spirit
or an individual who is lower again if
we want to use this little schema here
the old person has incorporated what the
person has and now they're going forward
and they're taking what they've got and
then this person takes what they've got
and they go forward with it as well
so you know we could think about this in
economic terms you know as wealth is
acquired families they are able to do
more with that wealth is if we think
about knowledge about the advances that
we we have seen in you know all sorts of
fields of knowledge we could think about
this in terms of the arts in terms of
the humanities in terms of learning how
to actually live a life where you're not
a jerk to other people all of these
sorts of things when we have progress
this is kind of this is gonna bother
some people the people who are back here
on the hind end they become these sort
of shadowy almost not entities except
insofar as they had something to
transfer to us they almost don't matter
as far as the universal process goes
except that's not really the case let's
go out and see what else he says says
the individual whose substance is the
more advanced spirit runs through this
past just as what it takes up a higher
science goes through the preparatory
studies in order to bring the content to
my tea recalls them to the inward I but
he has no lasting interest in them so
when we look again for example of the
master-slave dialectic we're not looking
at that because we think that's the
pattern for all human society this is
one way much a lot of people go warm in
interpreting Hegel we're looking at it
because it was important in the past and
did set the framework for things but
didn't absolutely determine them and
we're looking at it precisely because it
has been surpassed according to Hegel
not surpassed in the sense that you know
we've dealt with all violence all
expropriation all all you know
exploitation of human being by human
beings but because we've gone into more
complicated forms that are in a certain
respect more interesting and more
enduring and if we want to see where we
come to and fully understand we need to
look back into this past and look at all
the previous shapes of consciousness so
he says the single individual must pass
through the formative stages of
universal spirits so far as their
content is concerned but its shapes
which spirit is already left behind its
stages on a way that has been made level
with toil it's because of the work that
was done in the past that were able to
actually look back at the past and say
that's what was going on with them
that's what was important with them
doesn't have absolute importance the way
that they assume that it did let's think
for example about the Reformation and
the Wars of Religion and the fact that
these people were willing to not only
kill each other over that I mean getting
people to kill each other is not really
that that difficult what was really
troubling about the Wars of Religion was
that people were willing to lie and you
might say oh religion people are always
willing a lot well no do if you if you
if you look and you actually do your
historical research which doesn't just
mean reading some books or watching The
History Channel that means actually sort
of immersing yourself in the literature
of that time trying to get the mindset
trying to wrap your head around the
shapes of consciousness of that time you
realise that this really troubled people
that's just one example we can go back
and we can look but the path has been
made flat for us to go back and do so
and even more so since we've got to here
in a book which is supposed to
encapsulate all the important shapes of
consciousness so he says as far as
factual information is concerned we find
that what in former ages engaged the
attention of men and mature mind he has
been reduced to the level of facts
exercises and even games for children
think for example if you know anything
about the history of mathematics about
the development of the integral calculus
now most people you know if they're
doing high school they're not going to
actually get
calculus and most people are probably
not gonna study calculus if they go to
college but calculus is really you know
it's sort of a building block for
further things it's a lot of fun
actually but I have to I have to say
because I really enjoyed learning
calculus because I learned about you
know the theories of it's an
undergraduate the theory of limits
Leibniz had to work his butt off and so
did Isaac Newton in order to be able to
figure this stuff out how are you
measuring rates of change than to wrap
their heads around it it wasn't just
like playing with the numbers and
getting the numbers right it was coming
up with a metaphysics that then the
notation could go into and they actually
got into a big TIFF about who invented
it first we can teach it as a textbook
we can teach it to people who aren't
even particularly bright were motivated
because it's from that past so he says
in the child's progress through school
and this is of course somebody who
actually goes you know to a school where
people care where they teach things
where they're not totally distracted by
you know we could go out of that the
child progresses through school we shall
recognize the history of the cultural
development that the world traced as it
were in a silhouette in a silhouette now
think about what a silhouette is it's
not the thing itself it's only the image
of it and it's not even the full image
it's only the outline of it it says this
past experience is the already acquired
property of the universal spirit which
constitutes the sub the substance of the
individual and hence appears externally
to him as is in organic nature so you
know what education comes to us from the
outside we feel you know sometimes
educators want to say a new car a means
leading outward but actually a lot of
Education is just imposing stuff on
students and saying read this book and
do these exercises and it feels very
external why because the students have
not actually had these sort of formative
experiences dealing with as Hegel said
the patience
labor of the negative having to work
these things out but we're able to enter
into those sorts of things imaginatively
by looking at this entire progression
and focusing on the states of
consciousness and sort of placing
ourselves within the middle of the story
so he says in this respect formative
education a consistent acquiring what
lust lies to hand devouring is or
getting an organic nature taking
possession of of it but regarded from
the sight of universal spirit of
substance this is nothing but its own
acquisition of self-consciousness the
bringing about of its own becoming and
reflection into itself so there's
progress of of history the history of
human beings is leading to a limit point
where science can at last become
conscious of itself now known as to
again I've stressed this several times
science does not just mean the Natural
Sciences nor the Social Sciences visum
shopped and a galleon sense means
something that is systemic that tries to
extend itself to all of reality that
tries to make itself adequate even to
the individual to the particular that
does not reject things and say that's
not scientific we're not going to think
about it but tries to incorporate even
that that means that science has to
develop historical awareness which is
what the phenomenology is supposed to be
doing that's supposed to be providing us